[Music]
says we're going live says we're live we
are alive and hello everyone and welcome
to round table with the stream team and
this is where we talked to amazing
guests about - how they decided to
become content creators and what they
did where they became what they've kind
of grown into now so tonight we have
brought a very good friend of mine who
happened to be someone that we met in
PAX East last year of myself and MJ
actually believe it or not he was the
other man he was the man behind the
camera over there mr. Dano - I one
minute sir hello how are you I'm doing
well I'm doing doing quite well it's
it's been a spin it's love day but it's
it's not bad yes well thank you very
much for coming we I know that it's
today's your day off in the spirit world
so I appreciate you taking it you know
this hour to come hang out with us and
talk and chat about about everything
content creation and and you know some
games and you know just some fun stuff
in general so I appreciate you coming
thank you well thanks for thanks for
having me man pretty good thank you very
much
and we have our other panelists today we
have our our good old buddy MJ is a boss
what's going on MJ how are you I'm doing
good how about yourself
I'm - I'm doing well and and once again
you did not use your catchphrase what's
poppin that is your thinking got in the
chat oh you missed it I'm sorry you
gotta save it for this show that's it
for the show but I'll do it at the end
okay and and you heard you know our
amazing female co-panelist l-boogie Oh -
oh wait how are you well
I am good how are you doing on this like
horrible Monday Monday and go to work
good Monday it's like the day you got to
get up and you just like first day work
you gotta go you gotta go and then for
me it's Thursday and Thursday is my
other day of the week that I just like
yes I'm just like
and it's just painful and then once I
get there I'm good so well we're on time
so that I was like cool let let's hope
that sets the tone for the weekend you
know we're like not running late yes yes
I agree I agree so and thank you thank
you again for for joining us so so we we
are here I'm sorry I cut you off I
apologize so - good sir so yeah why
don't you why don't you give us your
your you know your story of becoming a
content creator and how you kind of
journey to become what you're doing
right now and and kind of how you're
growing once you go ahead and give us
that that story oh man um where I start
so way we wait that's legitimately was a
long time ago when I just started like
breaking things apart and kind of
talking about them in front of people so
back when I back about the end of high
school middle beginning of college which
was like 10 years ago - 11 years ago
Jesus
I was playing call of duty
professionally and started getting to
like the eSports before eSports were
called eSports we did not call them
eSports back then that's how old I am
so we started playing a bunch of
tournaments and a bunch of like you know
traveling up and down the west coast and
a lot of these things based on what like
you did back in the day it was climbing
ladders like MLG before MLG was MLG they
would call them game battles it before
MLG bought them up and then they became
their own thing so I started playing
that and that kind of brought me into a
whole different world about
entertainment and what it meant to be
doing stuff in front of people via video
games because you know that I'd play
sports and stuff like that so we
understand like what sports are sports
are very much a known thing and a very
popular thing at that point still and
then and then we started to learn about
what eSports were we just called it
competitive gaming at that point and
then that turned into a couple of guide
companies actually coming to our team
that I was mainly with for
long time and asked us to like be a part
of a strategy guide writing crew so we
had been doing something for like so
that our our clan leader was was as a is
a graphic artist so he like would make
old maps based on like so come when we
were playing SOCOM and then we
eventually moved him to a Call of Duty
and there's just like well do you feel
like making a thing for us and putting
it in a book and maybe consulting on
some of the strategy and we're like okay
we'll do that so they did that for a
couple books and then it happened to
happen to come about that I was I was a
writer and I was studying to be a writer
so they're like okay we want to go
actually like we'll just send you to go
do something like this and see what they
come out with and then then we did that
and I started getting into a strategy
guide writing and and that turned into
getting a little bit deeper and a little
bit deeper into what it meant to do like
entertainment inside the video game
world and then at one point throughout
college I started a radio station
started being on the radio and talking
about metal music and video games and
all kinds of stuff like that and then
that turned those two things combined
and they're like hey do you want to run
our twitch channel it's like um no I
have no idea what I'm doing there but
I'll try it without any idea but we're
figuring it out yeah so they're like
okay we're gonna start a we're gonna
start like a couple month plan to figure
that out I was like okay maybe it might
as well start my own channel and that's
when and it's one kind of if I started
the day Natasha name because my
competitor being was sabotage and my
name is Dan so I was like okay let's
just be creative and jam them two
together because that's how our
creativity works people and so slams
together you get a sandwich pretty much
yeah and then so so I did that and
started to kind of worked with somebody
else to build a community to start
raising money for extra life back when
we started that was like our reason for
like starting and in general and I was
like well that happens to be that that's
how it sounds like an awesome plan and I
gotta get I gotta bow t'what twitches
anyway so let's put those two together
and and then yeah that sort of started
my channel I started streaming
Borderlands 2 no Borderlands the
pre-sequel
with no mic with no camera I just
started streaming it and typing in chat
and and hanging out with like that three
or four people that would come by and
watch and and then and then it sort of
went from there I started I started like
putting together a camera putting all my
taking all my audio equipment out from
renting it out from from a radio station
and using that for a little bit and then
started putting together the couple
things there and I started learning
about I was I was you know the the
reason I was in college was for media
and film and audio and stuff like that
and writing more than anything because
it was communication so I started to
like put together a show and start to
put together a lot of the hardware that
went with it I sort of understood it
already so it was a nice big boost into
that so basically all the things started
to combine and then I just I just
started streaming i I mean as an author
and as an in school and being able to
kind of run my own schedule I was just
able to just start streaming it wasn't
streaming very long every day but I was
streaming like every day and people
started coming in started hanging out I
started meet a lot of cool people and I
started meeting streamers basically
immediately because I had already been
going to stuff like III and and and PACs
and whatnot so I started meeting people
almost immediately and then started
making friends and then it just kind of
went from there and started streaming
and streaming and streaming and then add
the streaming world just kind of grew up
at that point so it's been almost five
years now of full-time streaming and
yeah that's where we are today at the
end of the the long and short of it
really the low mature who was who was
your first who's your first streamer
that you met you kind of connected with
well there was a small group of them but
it there was one that kind of sparked it
so I had been following and watching
Tiger Ryder for a long time so I met him
at e3 who was there with scarfy know
back then she was obz Anka now it's
monkey ism and and death death sculpt
mm-hmm I think they're in Santa in Santa
so there was like a bunch of us we all
went to lunch started like you know
kicking it off and stuff like that and
just kind of set it off from there cuz
he had known me from his chat and he had
known that I screamed and stuff like
that so we started like just kind of
hanging out and it really nothing ever
really like came up as far as like how
that went and and then it was just like
okay cool let's like this is awesome you
guys are fantastic and you seemed pretty
nice and I was just like hey well let's
go see you later right after lunch after
lunch is over because he they were all
hanging out and was like see you later
great was it and then he asked me like
what are you doing tonight so well I'm
just kind of chilling with I had met a
lot of my co-workers there so it was
just like probably gonna get I don't
know if dinner or something like that
not really too much he's like we're
going to this twitch party and I know
that you just started streaming like
couple months ago so like do you want to
come I was like sure and I brought me in
and and we hung out that's where I met a
bunch of staff members that I'm still
friends with too today and and it turned
out that I got to meet a couple cool
people there too gooey bear who I'm
still really good friends with today
I've met it there for the first time and
we ended up hitting it off and and it
just kind of everything kind of
blossomed into something much bigger
because back then it wasn't a huge deal
to be going to like this twitch party it
was like one of the first twitch parties
that ever existed it was III 2014 or 15
or whatever now it's like nobody needle
go to the twitch party because it's too
packed because there's too many people
back then it was like no we need people
in here yeah so uh so they they were
just kind of all hung out there and had
a good time so yeah that was like some
of my first friends here on Twitch but
it's it's just grown since then I'm
still friends with Tiger Ryder still
friends with I actually everybody in
that group I don't talk to talk to
everybody is nearly as much but it is uh
they're there and there's we still hang
out and they're still good people and
you know never never we're gonna give up
those friendships cuz they're some of
the best feel we've ever known and yeah
it's just kind of gone from there now
these people they also they work for
direct which some of them none of those
people do but I did meet some people
they're like
who I guess one of the only ones I knew
from twitch at that point was who would
it have been siren I guess siren was the
event coordinator for like parties and
stuff at that point now she now she's
one of the assistants for running
twitchcon they met siren and she's the
one that helped me get into the party
and get into like the stuff and whatever
and then and then I found out that that
she lived in she she lived in which is
from San Diego obviously living in San
Francisco and then when we finally like
moved there and did a bunch of extra
life stuff together it was just like oh
we're just you know hanging out at
school so we kind of hit it off there
yeah that's pretty cool that's cool
now dude there's one thing you kind of
like skimmed over was the the some of
the stuff that we kind of spoke about
before when we were on the iron alloys
podcast is you did the competitive csgo
stuff correct I did a little bit csgo my
main gig was called beauty oh yeah and
then after a while you kind of evolved
and did other things and we you say you
did the right the the premium game
writing books correct it was prima or I
worked yeah so some of the the first
company ever worked with his piggy back
and then Brady games and then prima
games and then eventually Brady games
and prima games became one company with
a prima no yeah now I'm gonna I'm gonna
shameless plug for you I happen to have
this book right here so I figured I give
you that plug it's on Amazon if you
would like it that's a whole different
that's a whole different thing to yeah
yes but like I myself I went I actually
read it and I went through it and I
thought it was pretty interesting and it
kind of gives you know a little bit of a
background thought process of how some
of the thoughts and and how some of the
things you wouldn't imagine to make a
difference in your streaming life to end
up kind of helping you to to grow and to
build our community which which is it
was just pre is pretty nice and L
do you have any questions for for mr.
Danno while we're going so um so that's
it
cuz I'll sit here and I'll be dead Oh
I'll talk all day because we were
literally we were talking for almost 45
minutes before the before the show
started but uh did you have anything you
were thinking of I got one oh you got
one
go ahead them so when she first started
streaming what system are we on PC like
you said you were playing Borderlands
yeah
yeah I was on PC because I didn't have
any of the capture technology yet it was
back then it was still super expensive
like yeah to get one of the how Pasha's
was like 300 bucks which I I had that I
had that stuff but I didn't want to use
it because it was like specifically for
for work and guide writing and stuff at
that point but but yeah there was mostly
just PC stuff and then but I came from I
came from when I was playing call of
duty I was on Xbox so that was like the
main gig there and then eventually it
was mostly all PC because it was just
the easiest thing to do at that point
which Call of Duty I competed in one and
two and four the good ones all the
infinity warrant reward ones yeah all
that I should say the respawn ones
because most the people that worked on
those games don't work for Infinity Ward
anymore that's why it's so good we
respond that the team at respawn has
never made a bad game in my opinion all
the way from Call of Duty 1 and this I
praise so you got Call of Duty 1 Call of
Duty 2 Call of Duty 4 cuz I didn't do
they didn't do 3 and then most a team
went on to make a respawn which made
titanfall titanfall 2 Star Wars Jedi
fallen order and apex legends and all of
those are bangers right angry please
tell me a beta P even if you have to
lower the difficult
I recommend beating it it's just I
haven't I don't know like I just get
cool back into like multiplayer like
it's worth it it's not that long I would
say it's worth just going through it I
think I'm probably got like an hour left
like maybe two hours left like I just
got to just buckle down and just do it
cuz it's just greed I just gotta do it
it's just escape from tarkov it's just
like pulls me on I wanted to be better I
wanna do better so if you guys I'm sorry
I see a couple of people talking to chat
about the audio and the video and stuff
I actually got a new streaming system
here so I apologize if it's a little off
but just just know that your input is
helpful so going back to coming back to
Dan so when you when you decided to go
vol 2 the whole entire streaming realm
if you will so you kind of you could
have just evolved because you were is
already in that competitive space so
like ever like your family kind of knew
what you kind of did you kind of they
were okay with you go into that
streaming space and talking about that
type of stuff they don't really have any
idea cuz like I was working I was
working for so while I was while I was
when I first started it like because I
was a freelancer right so I never really
had a real job at prima games right I
was just a freelancer I basically got
whatever jobs they decided to give me so
there's nothing guaranteed there so I at
for a long time I never left my job my
full-time job before that so I had a
full-time job was working about 50 hours
a week going to school three to four
days a week depending on the semester
and then in between that streaming for
like three days after work or three yeah
three days a week about three hours I
know sorry everyday three hours a day
after work and just kind of resting it
that way and then when there was a job I
actually wouldn't stream for a while so
I would I would you know sort of try to
figure out what I'm doing there and
sometimes there was travel going on
sometimes I had to lie to my job and say
I'm sick when I cuz they wouldn't give
me the time
mom I hated that job with a passion I
did it for I did that for four years
Wallace it was I'm not gonna say who it
was but it was it was a food product
company I would say it like they did and
basically what I did and you probably
figured out if you if you ever worked in
a grocery store or something like this
but I would do is I would go to grocery
stores and I would basically stock our
shelves whatever our product was I would
stock our shelves but that also meant
like we'd have to build like the huge
displays that you see in the stores you
have to like truck out you know
thousands of pounds of product every
single day and it was just like it was
killing me
it was legitimately like physically and
everything killing me because like I was
I was in shape but I wasn't like nearly
as strong as I am today and it just
became it was exhausting working like 12
to 13 to 14 hours a day and then still
coming home and trying to stream it was
it was rough and and the pay was while
it paid my bills and paid my rent and
stuff like that well seriously didn't
seem like like that much even after all
the hot of the holiday pay and overtime
and even being in a union it was it was
hell but it definitely taught me I'd
worked several retail jobs before that
too but it definitely taught me what it
what it was like to do something you
don't want to do for so long and gave me
kind of the drive to go do something
else but but it was still scary because
you could never quit it right everything
else I was doing was never gonna pay the
bills but but I was jumping on something
that was a little bit risky and stuff
like that so to go back and answer your
question my parents did really and my
family never really knew they liked even
today they know what I do but they don't
really understand but they never really
knew what I was doing because it was
sort of this it was just a side thing
and when I was doing like books and
stuff like that every now and that I did
you know there'd be like a call of duty
or something that would come out and my
mom would go buy one of the books and
she'd give it to my little brother and
like when I came home for Christmas or
something like that I would assign it
for her and stuff like that so it they
she they very much
appreciated that I was doing something
in some sort of spotlight but they had
really had no idea what it was so they
were as probably as supportive as they
could be without knowing anything really
like not because not because they just
not because I kept a secret they just I
knew they wouldn't understand and when I
would try to explain it they still
didn't understand so it just kind of
went on that way yeah it seems like
that's that's what the the global
thought process is with a lot of parents
from from a lot of people that we've
spoken to their their parents or family
or anyone when you talk to them about
you know wanting to stream or what you
do is streaming or content creation if
you will it's like they don't understand
fully understand what it is
so I kind of feel like it's more of a
generational thing like we understand it
and you know when we have kids they'll
understand it because well like we'll
understand for them but like right now
like my parents I told them I'm like 9
o'clock please don't open the door don't
ask your questions don't call me because
you don't understand how your computer
works I have to do I have to do this
podcast with friends of mine so let like
I have to kind of inform them of those
things but they're kind of just like
what is a podcast and I'm not get
downloaded if my parents for my mom and
my mom's like I don't even know how to
play this and listen to it I was like ok
mom it's ok it's it's in layers you know
you can you can talk about this in many
layers like my stepdad he pretty much he
gets it like he showed up in my channel
many times he he knows what's going on
he's there too he's usually there to
troll me too because he's just that kind
of guy he's like yeah you know who's
this guy on the screen I this isn't the
channel I flip to stuff like that yeah
you know he'll sit there in trolled me
he just he just kind of understands it
that way my mom just kind of gets the
the spillover of whatever he tells my
dad has asked basically every holiday
what it to explain to him what it is
because he knows what it is but he
doesn't were going
right now and I am recording as we speak
so okay so I guess we'll just start from
here and I'll just merge the videos and
then I'll upload them and clean them up
go all right more more things for me to
do fantastic like we were saying before
Daniel as we're always sitting by the
computer
there's always something there's always
something yes so alright so we talked
before about you know your family and
everything and how they kind of didn't
understand and and that was kind of
those that's very interesting how they
kind of you know they didn't understand
and and and now you kind of have to
explain it and that was very interesting
do you do you have a like a thought or
remember of like the first time you were
gaming like you were like couch just
like playing games with like family
friends or something I remember the
first time I mean I remember the first
game I played what was that that was
actually the Tasmanian Devil game which
is called Taz ta Z on the Atari 2600 I
was young I was definitely very very
young but that was at my grandma's house
actually cuz she would watch me for the
majority of my early early life and she
she actually liked for a grandma she was
a gamer like she had that not because of
me she had that because she wanted it so
she had like several games and stuff
like that for the Atari later on she got
like a gameboy and she'd have like the
original super like Mario on there and a
few other things and then now she like
pretty much every Christmas we get her
either an update two or whatever tablet
she's using or give her some like Amazon
gift cards or something like that she
usually like buys like the casino games
on there so she still plays those every
now and then yeah that's she's kind of
who got me started there
because she just always had it and I
would it was always available so I was
like all right cool
so you haven't playing games since like
I can actually remember yeah all over
the place yeah now from when I remember
you from the other podcast you said that
your grandma was kind of like almost
like a partial inspiration for you to
play games because she was she had I'm
so available for you yeah I mean like
there wasn't much for us to do like it
was I was an only child I didn't really
have any at least on that especially on
that side I'd have any cousins I didn't
really have many people because like my
parents been split up since I was young
and so when I was with my mom I was with
I was with my grandma and she like we
didn't really have any too many too many
other people around my age around that
time so when I was there we dealer you
know we we so I spend a lot of time with
my grandparents cuz while my grandmother
was working at the time
my grandfather he had been like been
discharged from the Army and he was he
was on disability so he like it couldn't
couldn't really do much for work he was
basically retired at that point so it's
been like most of my days with him and
you know obviously a lot of cartoons a
lot of football he really was a bit he
was a huge Oakland Raiders fan and and
then every now and then we died I play
on the game boy or in the Atari star in
the room so it was just kind of like
that was that was where I spent most of
my days there was really nothing else to
do for me
at that point so it was it was almost
like I was forced into video games but
also something that I just wanted to do
anyway so yeah it's just it was kind of
there and there wasn't that really it
was kind of the only thing I had in
front of me you know so so you had that
and you kind of pushed through so like
what like did she have like a what like
did they have like a wide assortment of
different things for you I don't
remember I don't think so cuz like the
only that's like Kaz is like the one
that sticks in my brain the most outside
of that I'm pretty sure I played like
like tank or something like that with
tank babel or whatever the heck
called this prodigious called battle
play a little bit of that I think at a
certain point there's always been like
this this kind of addictive personality
to video games because like I had been
I've been through so many different like
people watching me like I was I was that
like professional babysitters I was at
like you know daycares and all kinds of
stuff and and really like if there was
like a little game in the corner if
there was some type of game that's where
I was and that's what I was going to do
so like there was always this I don't
want to deal with anybody else I just
want to play this video game no matter
what I would you know but there was like
there was times where I would sneak in
the other room at this babysitter's
house because she used to watch like
these other two twins and like another
person and there was sort of like four
of us but like you know I kind of I was
like I don't really I don't see myself
connecting with these guys cuz they had
all been you know being watched by this
lady for like years so they all knew
each other I was kind of the odd man out
and then and then I saw that they had
like this I think it was a Nintendo it
was it was Super Mario Brothers 3 that
they hadn't that she had in the other
room I'm like I would sneak over there
and start playing I don't think she even
knew about it so I don't know if she was
a good babysitter or what but just start
playing it and then eventually they
figured out it's like oh he actually
likes this okay well well let him play
this every like couple days or whatever
because it was like her son's or
something like that so yeah that was
like Super Mario Brothers 3 and then you
know a couple of like classics back then
but for the most part it was just
whatever was there and those that those
only ones I really remember too much mhm
you know so like Taz was the big one in
Super Mario Brothers 3 a little bit duck
hunt cuz I think my grandpa had like
duck hunt at one point but he would be
the one playing it I wouldn't really let
his grandchildren play with it too much
when I was playing talked on with when I
was a kid my dad would always yell at
the dog and he was always trying to
shoot the dog and he would always issue
the shot like right before the next
match so he'd have one less bullet and
he's like dude what good if you get all
mad about it
they're those those are those are those
funny memories that you that you have oh
yeah wait a minute when you're younger
for uh for the next upcoming year do you
do you see yourself going to any new or
I should say at different conventions it
like we've talked about it before like
you said you know you don't think you're
gonna make it to PAX East this year
because of the timing of everything
going on in your life but like what
about like III or twitchcon or something
like that or well I assume you're going
to gcx since you pretty much helped run
the whole thing so yeah so both both
early year paksas I those are two my
favorites sorry to have never been I've
never been to pax West but both back
south and PAX East I like those a lot
unfortunately this time of year yeah
we're moving we're dealing with all
kinds of new stuff happening so it's
just like I'm doing my best not to
travel
so when stay home figure that out and
then and then so not gonna do those this
year but that doesn't mean I don't ever
want to do them again just just not this
year and then I'd love to go to pax West
but like everything I know about pax for
us is just that it's a mayhem crazy show
and I don't know if I want to deal with
that same with my games come like I
would love to go to Germany and go to
games come but unfortunately it's just
it's a whole lot of commitment for what
seems to be a very impossible to see or
do anything to kind of show so I'm
trying to weigh out the options there
plus again every time I you know as a
streamer has a content creator of any
sort well I guess YouTube's a little bit
different cuz you can just record a
bunch of stuff and release it I envy
youtubers really really much bear it
badly but but you know taking them more
more time you take off the more damage
you kind of do to your channel and what
you do and stuff like that so it's very
careful with it so so time off is
getting well actually I should say
travel to conventions is getting less
and less every year but that's also
because I do have two or three
conventions that I pretty much have to
hit up and when you set it so basically
I'll be moving
I'll be moving to LA so I'll be pretty
close to e3 no matter what so it's
basically like this again like like
twitchcon this year it's like doing work
not to go because living in San Diego
for the last four years has been pretty
easy to make it to twitchcon and stuff
like that yeah but ya know III and then
and then gcx obviously at gcx is this
you know it's a company it's a
convention that i work for so it's
definitely something I'll be at um let
me am i not blinking on you now
yeah you're better I can smell okay good
yeah cuz I saw it and I was like that
it's gotta be aggravating to you so I'm
sorry like I said this is this is
annoying because I had tested all the
stuff before and everything was going
good I deal with this stuff every day I
that's one of those things like as a
streamer as a content creator you are
everything you know and part of one of
those things is your technical support
yeah I'm just gonna I'm just gonna start
rolling it's just some commissions cuz
you just brought that up to you yeah do
you feel like you have to wear too many
hats when you're doing all this on your
own um too many I mean I don't mind
wearing a ton of hats that's that's the
difference is like I I do think it's a
lot of hats I think it's often too many
hats but that's kind of the it's kind of
the way of a millennial mmm and I don't
mean that in like a derogatory term
that's like that's just kind of how we
are in this in this generation we're
forced to do a little bit of everything
it's the gig economy too it's the same
thing that like an uber driver has or
like a door - person does like that's
not their full-time job I would I would
imagine they probably do all kinds of
things they could be streamers and
youtubers like for all I know it's a
it's a decent gig for something like
that because you can make your own
schedule contractors all over the place
but yeah it's it's kind of the nature of
the job I do I think it's too much I I
do but there's like it's hard to figure
out what kind of choice you have
thankfully doing this as long as I have
I've been able to meet people who have
helped me a ton obviously like you know
have your moderators and your team and
people that are they got your back and
be able to help you in those ways so it
takes a little bit off of your shoulders
but now having a management team that's
got my back the whole time like I don't
have to deal with arguing with other
companies about hey man you want to
charge me what are you sorry not you you
want to pay me you want to pay me
nothing to you know promote your game I
don't have to deal with that I have
somebody else that deals with that which
is which is great because as much as I
don't mind dealing with that that's even
more time I don't have for all the other
things you know yeah yeah and then me as
an author and as I'm writing more books
and stuff like that I do more than just
that so it gets kind of crazy it's it's
pretty it's pretty cool how you kind of
been able to kind of grow all you like
you different kinds of little your hats
if you will we kind of look because you
you've been doing this for so long now
going back to to gcx like how did you
end up getting involved in gcx and how
did you kind of been there you've been
there for a couple of years now right
yeah I've been it's been yeah this will
be the third year I'm working with them
with the people over at rare drop so
pretty much everybody at rare drop and
including myself for all like again
managed by the same company plus like
I've kind of gotten to know like
professor bro man pretty well he him and
I have him and I have had a lot of
common verses like again wearing a ton
of hats and wanting to do a bunch of
things for for streaming and content
creation like we both started on Twitch
for charity and like this was hold
earlier it's like we had that I have
other reasons to be on a content
creation platform but the main reason
was to start gaining a community and
raising money for for charity and so we
hit it off that way there was one time
he needed something from a connection
that I had and he he basically I did I I
put my connection forward and basically
made it so he didn't really have to do
much after that and I guess he just
liked
and it turned into hey man we're looking
for we really are missing this area mmm
for for you know Guardian con at that
point because I kind of went to him was
like hey man I really like I dig
Guardian con I really think it's a it's
a great adventure and what you guys are
doing and the fact that we already had
kind of a rapport going and we kind of
knew each other for a little bit and
we've been you know around the same
circles for a little bit he kind of knew
what I was about and what I could do and
he's like hey man we really need this
can you do this you seem like you can
probably handle it and so I was like
yeah we'll try it out and figure out
what's going on and then you know when
when I was able to kind of show that
then I could get some of that stuff done
which was you know getting them in front
of certain like news outlets like
getting them in news getting gcx in news
weekend and helping with some of their
Tampa news and and Florida that just
outlets in general they're like okay
well this is this is working out we can
do this we can make this work
gotten a little bit closer with their
their like marketing team and I was able
to actually like prove because a lot of
people don't understand that marketing
and public relations are two different
things I'm like I can work with your
marketing team but I'm not marketing and
then it's like wait how do what do you
mean what it was the difference here and
then we kind of showed that it's like
marketing is going to sell who you are
and sell what's going on here PR is
gonna make sure that that all is
accurate and nobody's confused by what's
going on and then if people have
complaints you're able to your PR team
is able to handle those and what's and
give them the right information they're
the marketing is going to basically say
hey we need we are this is who we are
come to our show it's a little different
and I was able to show that and between
that and the you know a lots of the
friends that I've made over the years
it's it's it's it's a pain in the ass
job will tell you that yeah but we all
know that because it's one of those
things to where we're in the we're in a
media spotlight now to where unless it's
drama drama
unless it's dramatic nobody wants to
write about it right so when I come when
when I go and I say hey man we've got
this big you know marathon going on
similar to something like gdq raising
money for the same the people over at
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital do
you want to like help promote it and
like talk about something that's like
good in the world and 99% of the time I
get no response but every now and then
like Mike Newsweek I'm gonna keep
promoting them because they actually
like he did a really good job they'll
talk about it and and then all of a
sudden we do the marathon it raised over
four million dollars mhm and just dr.
Lupo himself raises several million in
just one four-hour block and you're
almost a million and actually it wasn't
a million and for one four-hour block
it's like okay now I get all these
emails are like hey man we want to write
about dr. Lupo doing all this stuff I
think did you did you get the email I
sent you like six months ago when we
told you this was gonna happen it's like
oh yeah yeah but we didn't know what was
going on it's like you will kind of just
defeat responded to my email and I would
have helped you out there so that's
that's basically my job there's is I get
to tell people I told you so which is
like it's like dude I'm telling you
right now this is going to be a huge
year we're gonna raise millions of
dollars in fact I was quoting to them
three million dollars we're gonna
guarantee I would didn't guarantee but I
was like I I promise we're gonna raise a
lot of money and we're shooting for
three million dollars this year when we
shot over four million dollars and I was
able to say hey I told you so it's just
like it's it's it feels good because
obviously it's for the kids but that's
that's how it became part of it was I
was able to handle those situations and
I enjoy handling those situations in
fact I don't know if anybody that works
at battle State Games listens to your
pond guess what if they do you can hire
me and I'll get rid of this nightmare
you have going on but yeah it's it's
basically I my I'm good at putting out
fires in the public and making sure
everybody understands things because a
lot of people they have good intentions
but they don't know how to say them and
that's where I come in and that's and I
was able to prove that which is why I've
been able to get involved in companies
like this yeah because
of how destiny can kind of gradually
gradually changed into what is what is
gcx and kind of the destiny community
meet up yeah yeah because I don't think
anyone thought it was gonna be this huge
a helping hand for community but for
like not community for charity but
charity yeah a charity and from
conversations I've had with you and tell
like you and the other streamers who are
kind of on the forefront of that kind of
they have these generous hearts because
you you've done didn't I'm trying to
think of you've done multiple charities
from how long I've known you because
you've done the st. Jude's like you're
saying charities since since the day we
started for so like four five years
we've done a bunch like yeah there's
like harder yeah go ahead that's right
didn't you do one for for veterans
getting games also
yeah stack up I've worked with stack up
I've worked with Steve Meshuga for a
long time in fact I worked with him
before he started stack up because he
was he was the I mean he was also the
creator of what the heck was the last
for operations supply drop and then he
would just they they didn't click or
whatever was going on there I don't
actually know and he went and created
stack up and I worked with them for a
while
like and then yeah so I've worked with
him I've worked with a ton of different
charities and like the biggest problem
with working with so many charities is
like you feel bad that you can't do it
was something every year or something
every couple of months or something like
that because it's like I do a lot of
charity broadcast but you do if you
let's say you do for a year or five a
year you do four or five different ones
every year that's that comes down to
possibly working with that specific
charity once every a year and a half or
two years and it's like they're it's
it's it's hard to say hey man I know we
haven't done anything in a while but I
still care about you guys and it's
because like you know I when it comes to
when it comes to helping veterans out
that's
have been a huge piece through my video
through my education so that's close to
my heart but like you know kids with
cancer that's close to my heart
animals and people and you know right
now in Australia that's close to mine
it's like I mean you you know the time I
stream like a lot of my viewership is
Australian so it's like that that's
those are as much as I'm not Australian
those are my people so you know it's
it's it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking to not be able to do so
much and to know that however much I've
done I still don't have like this huge
following that can do something every
time that we want to put something
together it gets a little tough
sometimes but at the same time you know
it doesn't it doesn't stop me and it's
never going to be that that super
discouraging thing but you know it's it
comes down to what you do not
necessarily what others do for you and
in these cases so as long as we try and
as long as we do something feel good
about it but you know it's never enough
when it comes to that I was happy to see
that mixer is doing stuff I guess that
they're gonna make a tour it's easier
for streamers to go ahead and do charity
streams for them are they integrating
within that's cool yeah let me pull up
the tweet well actually she shoes on
mixer and yeah okay so you can donate or
join the campaign and then they give you
the Australia wildlife relief website
and it says mixer content creators and
community are coming together to support
the Australian wildfire relief effort so
it's certified though right
the website is a kms / Australian
wildfire yeah so that takes it to tilt
the Phi so till the fire is actually a
client actually at the bottom yeah
defines a company that I've worked with
a lot there are a lot of good people
there too
people that I've come up with just as
streamers some of the people that I've
I've learned and just become friends
with before they even started working
for Delta Phi's so like my friends I
Casper and Ashley Ann and a bunch of
those people work for this company now
Ben we're able to work very closely with
them like the cool thing about what
they're doing is its run by streamers so
they're able to be able to give
streamers what they want or what they
need in order to do these broadcasts
just at the end of this month we'll be
doing probably one of one of my last
streams before I start moving moving
will be a big support supporting stream
for the Red Cross of Australia and that
the only way we can do that properly is
if a company like tilta five makes it
fully integrated I told you earlier one
of the first people I met from the
streaming world was Santa his name's
Josh and he's one of their main
programming consultants so he's the guy
that like makes sure that it works for
anybody that's doing a stream so so yeah
companies like this are huge lifesavers
when it comes to being able to do that
on a stream and actually make it so that
people know what's going on and it's
cool that it's cool that places like
twitch mixer and YouTube definitely help
with at least helping with that
integration and giving giving them the
tools to be able to integrate it as much
as much as they can yeah because I feel
I feel like the charity streams is it's
really nice because you do get to help
you know your causes do you feel that
doing those charity streams also helps
your channel to show how like you know
let me know your community I should say
not your challenge but I can make them
more unified and more like hey we have a
purpose this is what we want to do this
is what we enjoy doing kind of like this
little kind of like a like a bond all
right yeah in a way I would say I would
say that there's definitely a
camaraderie of hey we're all coming
together to go towards a cause yeah sure
I mean none of this would be
possible without without a community
that cares about the same thing right
because you can have you can have a a
charity broadcast that only affects one
percent of your community and that only
that one percent donates mm-hmm well
that's usually never the case it's
usually like a much bigger percentage
than just one percent mm-hmm and if it
only affects that one percent well if
you already if you obviously have a
bigger percentage that's that's donating
it means that yeah there's a connection
going on there we care about our fellow
community members they definitely like
it I would say that it's more of a
result rather than an effect or a a
cause rather it's an effect more than it
is a cause because there are a lot of
people out there that have used hey I'm
gonna do it [ __ ] one charity stream a
month and in the back of their head I am
I haven't I've never heard anybody say
this but it's it's hard not to imagine
the back of their head that they're
saying well if I do this I'm gonna look
really good and if I look really good to
the people that let's start following my
channel and you know I've seen that many
times I seen a lot of people hide hide
their their selfishness behind charities
in fact like the people some of the
people I've come up with have started
doing that or at least they were doing
that the whole time I never really
noticed
obviously I'll never say who those
people are but that has happened so many
times that it's it's the charity world
it becomes a little bit tricky in a
little bit sticky and you have to sort
of watch your step every now and then
but there's there's definitely there's
definitely those that have used charity
to to help of their channels and help
their careers so while I think that it
is possible I don't think it's as I
don't think it's as possible as a lot of
these people think that it is because I
mean you think about it what's going on
is you're actually charity doing charity
streams more often than not probably
hurt your channel unless you have this
very lucky strand of you have a bunch of
followers that really just care about a
lot of
if it's and causes and whatnot I'll tell
you right now most of the people in the
internet do not care about helping
others they don't it's it's unfortunate
but you if you bring people together and
you become that influencer and influence
people that you're doing a good thing
they can they will help and they will
they will try to do something good
because a lot of communities as a whole
are really good so in a way does it does
kind of both it does help your your
channel a bunch but it also very much
comes to a point where it's like well if
we help now we're not gonna help later
or something like that because we people
only have so much money obviously yes
yes and that's that's kind of a it's
kind of a good point that you brought up
that a lot of people you know they only
had they have like their set finances
and setting comes and you know they
can't consider consistently like give to
like a charity every month because
you're you're expecting them to get you
know drop hundreds of dollars in your
channel it's it's just it's something
that's not gonna happen
I I personally I do one or two months
out of the out of the year and I say all
the bits and everything and all my subs
and everything I get for these this
month it's going to this charity yeah do
do what you feel is appropriate I'm not
gonna force you like that's that's what
I want to do because I'm very passionate
about like you know animals and like the
guinea pig community because of what has
happened to me in the past with them and
I know that there's a bunch of rescues
larger ones in an LA actually that I
usually give to them every year it's
just one of those things that it's kind
of a it's an interesting it's just a
thing just to change to change the vibe
a little so the games that you've been
playing um you've been playing tarkoff
obviously because you and I have been
playing that and it's been fantastic
right now your your Monster Hunter and
you you are pumped about Monster Hunter
how do you how do you feel about the new
Monster Hunter version right now
ice-born have you have you started to
get into that content yet yeah we got
into it a little bit in the past
couple days so I played on ps4 I played
the whole through all the way through
the base game when it first launched it
took me like about a month to get
through absolutely everything and for
anybody who's watched my stream will
know that I've been playing I've been
playing monster for about eight years
like basically since the second game
came out and when when world came out I
was actually very disappointed it felt
like a much more much muddied down
watered down version of what Monster
Hunter really was obviously they made it
prettier they made it a lot easier to
play and access based on a being on like
a a full on console and putting it later
on PC and stuff like that I thought it
was a really big and good addition to
the Monster Hunter series in general but
as a veteran it just kind of felt it
felt too easy it felt muddied down it
felt like they took a lot of things out
with ice-born it feels like they are
putting that all back in granted they're
charging 50 bucks for the for the DLC
but they're putting all the things back
in so we used to have this thing called
G rink which was the really like them
much more difficult ranks and monsters
that came out of there now it's called
master rank because instead of doing the
same monsters but harder they've kind of
they've added a lot more monsters and
it's in a new map and there's new new
items and new weapon moves and new armor
sets and stuff like that so they've
turned it into something completely
different but with the same vibe as it
felt classically so they brought a lot
of that feel back and now it finally
feels like Monster Hunter again I'm
super happy about it yeah yeah because
I've seen how excited you are when
you're playing it and I feel like they
kind of from from the times that I've
seen the quezada I haven't played the
past versions of Monster Hunter I kind
of wonder if Capcom most people happen
but you think yeah I wonder if Capcom
was kind of like dipping their toes in
the water so to speak to see if people
were gonna buy it the the the first
mission and now that they saw it they're
like oh well this is perfect we're gonna
be able to put we'll put it like you
know expansion out and we'll put
everything in there that we originally
wanted to do kind of like just a little
teaser so I kind of I kind of enjoy I
kind of enjoy watching you you play it
million times better than I do I I have
lots of experience I am horrible like I
thought I was doing pretty well my god
this is good this is good know what you
played I was like I'm terrible I'm just
gonna stick to my first-person shooters
I'm like I'm good
they're pretty obvious about a lot of
that in their story and how they tell it
because the whole story behind it all
cuz a lot of them a lot of monsters
actually like some of them are kind of
in the same world and story together
there's like I would say four out of the
like twelve games that there are there's
like four different timelines or world
sort of this was there generations I
think yeah I guess you would call it
this is sort of this is all brand new
like this is nothing from before effects
now and that's kind of the story they've
told which is hey this is a new world
this is everything pretend this is a
brand new series we've never touched
this before what have you it there they
seemed pretty obvious about the fact
that they wanted players that have never
played their game before to come in and
they wanted to focus on that I think a
lot of Monster Hunter veterans because
the communities it community can be a
little elitist I wouldn't say toxic but
elitist a lot of the veterans would sit
there and say well this game is not for
me and I'm offended when I'm sitting
here saying the game's not for me but I
understand who it's for and I'm actually
happy about that because it basically
Monster Hunters a Japanese game like
it's always been a Japanese game that's
why it's always been on handhelds a lot
of us Westerners were like a tenth of
the population if that were probably
like a hundredth of the population that
we're playing monster on there were a
very small part of it if you look at the
numbers now which I don't know what they
are but I'd be willing to guess that
we're probably close to a third or even
half now because we brought a lot of
people have never even heard or even
thought about playing this series or it
never looked attractive to them and they
lied attractive to them until world came
out it's like oh my god I can actually
play this because it looks like a modern
and game that I can play now and that's
pretty much that's very much what it was
right so yeah it the game wasn't it
wasn't for me it wasn't first
buddy who's been playing monster under
for years it really wasn't ah now it
kind of is it's unfortunate that you had
to buy it twice but at the same time it
kind of is and some people have bought
it four times on you know their console
and then again on PC because the release
yes so yeah I definitely I bought it so
I bought the base game twice and then
thankfully I was given the I was given
ice-born by Capcom which was cool but
yeah yeah it's it's um it's definitely
nice having it on PC too because it was
like the for it's the first month's room
you can get you know a nice performance
out of yes yes it's beautiful and MJ do
you have any questions for Dan oh I
didn't know I think we just like run
through the paces now one of the last
questions that I like to ask every every
guest that comes on is what type of
world would or universe would you like
to live in they talked about like from
from video games specifically video
games books movies like anywhere you I
thought about this question actually a
lot in my life and it's tough because
usually if it's in something there's
usually something really bad happening
in it that's what a lot of people have
said because like you're like oh I
really loved Mass Effect coming up and
you're like but Mass Effect was
basically like all of earth was under
fire by Reapers and then at some point
you couldn't go anywhere else without
there being like these mercenary groups
trying to hunt you down it was it was
like you don't have to be the
protagonist to be in danger there but
yeah you know you can you there's people
that have said things like I like to
live in the world the star wars back in
the days of the Old Republic when it
wasn't like you know everyone was in war
but like you know like things like that
you part of the Old Republic you're
talking about like was was under the as
much as I mean it depends on if you were
born in a citroen as well like it
depends on like where you are you don't
get to choose everything
because the the Republic itself was
pretty nice but there was a lot of you
know it's a lot of bad places there too
however the Sith were not there was no
rule of two in the Old Republic it was
there was sit where an entire race and
owned many cities and planets all kinds
of stuff they were and they were
basically trial by fire type of beings
to where if you weren't tough you were
basically killed essentially I think
that would be as far as like things go
as a normalcy I'm assuming you're
talking about being a just a normal
person right like not being special in
any way you can say however which way
you want cuz we've had people that said
I want to be spider-man or I want to be
a person in the Marvel Universe you know
like just a regular guy or I want to be
a guy with superpowers and there's you
know you don't have to specifically do
it like you know you want to be like a
moisture farmer on Tatooine you could
see anything um let's see I would hmm
it's tough I think that if anything I
would like to be it has to be like a
citizen in something like a star to
valley or something like that to where
almost like almost like your goal is
just to not be too unhappy like it's
almost impossible to be happy fully
because you're just there and you can
farm and you can have a shop and you
live in this little town where nothing
really affects you it's kind of a it's
kind of a utopia in a lot of ways and I
play they give a lot so I do know a lot
about it which is nice but yeah it's it
seems it seems nice while there's
challenges and stuff that keep you going
it's totally unrealistic but it's still
it's something that it's not it's not a
garbage planet like everything else that
video games are about which is like
don't it's I mean that's the thing is
it's not bad because that's what keeps
things in your interesting right yes I
could be cool to live in night City and
cyberpunk but it would also be terrible
so yeah I can't wait for cyberpunk it's
gonna be so interesting it's gonna be so
much fun to watch and play that game I'm
excited to come out this year yeah a
couple more months yeah we're like
almost under a hundred days
is it March it's coming up March April
mm yeah March birthday person so so
anyway Danno thank you very much for
coming thank you thank you very much for
dealing with all of the video audio
problems I am so sorry a lot to have you
back one day when we don't have any more
problems so was I kind of cleaning
everything up I you know me I get it man
yeah I still get it yes I do and I
appreciate it so today now why don't you
tell everybody where they can find you
I'm sure you can find me pretty much
everywhere at Danno Taj DEA and OTA GE
most of my main places are on twitch I
do upload to YouTube every day so if you
want a duty I need more subscribers
there guys it's like impossible to get
subscribers on YouTube for some reason
even though I can get the many many on
twitch but yeah that's you can find me
there and Twitter I do make up stuff a
lot of the time but Twitter is kind of a
garbage place to so I kind of if you
want to if you if you want to give me a
positive interaction and I can feel good
about it on Twitter that'll be your best
friend so come hang out with me there
but you'll see a lot of my my
powerlifting and workout stuff on
Instagram as well so whatever it
whatever you like there's something out
there with my name on it for you
probably I don't know yes there is and I
wanted to talk about your your workout
regiments and all that stuff too but you
know I don't I don't want to I don't
want to hold everybody for that long
today but that'll be a whole nother
podcast yes yes lost fourth to do that
one day definitely definitely do that
MJ good sir what's poppin so I tell us
where we can find you your times and
what fun stuff you can find me on the
mixer at beep 10 and then you can find
me on twitch NJ as a boss they can find
me on snapchat at baby I'm excellent
thank you sir and you enjoy your college
life as your new semester
and I am not envious of you with your
homework you can find me on mixer at L
Baguio 208 I just got some really cool
updated banners for my about Me section
provided by De Niro yeah and I just
wanted to make sure I said it right
sorry but yeah he does a really good job
and yeah I have a schedule now 7 p.m. to
9 p.m. weekdays
except for Monday because I do this so
yeah oh and on Twitter same name you can
find it's all wherever L is so exactly
exactly
excellent why don't you do a shout out
for what happened for you over the
weekend - yeah so we had our hundredth
episode of growing my gaming we do that
on Saturday mornings on YouTube and we
did a bunch of giveaways and yeah pretty
stoked about that keep going strong and
hopefully all of us get out - III this
year yeah I was I was in the channel for
most of the time I didn't talk because
you battle a bunch of people in there
chatting away so it was it was a very
very great podcast and a great great you
know great time and seeing the
interaction with all of you ladies
together it's great and I like you know
I I'm always lurking but I sometimes
don't get time to listen but this time I
didn't have to listen it was good this
cool yeah so thanks for thanks for being
able to you know enlighten us and make
us laugh on that because you know you
you are a shining star in that so yeah
hopefully we can bring some of the
ladies on here also right yeah I need to
please do so as everyone knows my name
is snow though SN al why do I am on
twitch Twitter discord and
in our our let's chat always so if you
guys want to find me there I'm there
thank I thank everybody for hanging out
thanks if you have any comments or
questions or anything leave them down
below I'm gonna take this cut it up and
fix it up and put it up as one large
video Danna once again thank you very
very much for hanging out with you and I
appreciate you taking you know time out
of your busy schedule for hanging with
us and and everything will be on on all
the youtubes in YouTube's the podcasts
iTunes and things like that on Wednesday
morning when you guys wake up if you
have any questions please email us at
round table stream team at gmail.com and
we will be able to ask our guests those
questions and we have our Twitter which
is table stream if you want to go there
and you want to see when we end up
having guests come out or when we have
new notifications new fun stuffs coming
up
please go follow us there and I'd like
to say thank you very much and remember
everyone to dream big and keep gaming
and hopefully we'll see everybody next
week all right everybody thank you